Let's seek the Lord together on day number five.
Father, we praise you today
for revealing holiness to us, not just as unapproachable
light where we would be convinced that we could never be
holy.
We can never be a spirit like you with all power and all
knowledge.
We can never be holy in human form, and yet you have showed
us and revealed to us
that humanity and holiness can coexist
in the name and in the person of your son, Jesus.
So Lord, we have one deep, supreme desire
that we might be like Jesus.
I praise you, Lord, for my prayer partner who is here praying with me
today. I praise you for the desire that you've put within us
to be like Jesus. Like David said, "When I awake, I will be
satisfied with your likeness."
Oh God, we want to be like Christ. We want to keep our mind
fixed and stayed upon him, not focusing on ourselves or
our own
lack of strength, our own lack of ability.
Lord, we've looked for too long at ourselves and never
seen anything good happen by just looking at ourselves.
But we look to Jesus today
as the source and the definition of holiness.
Oh God, help us to look up to him and be
changed into his image with ever-increasing glory.
Thank you, Father, for showing us what human holiness really does look
like, and we rest upon that. We trust in it today.
We ask that the Holy Spirit would use the image
and the picture of Jesus to inspire us and help us long
for holiness today. Thank you, Jesus, for being our supreme
example.
Let's continue to pray together and ask the Lord to bless and
work in our hearts as we pray.